- Hello, Believe Nation!
I started the Mentor Me series
with a goal to hang around
people who've done more than us
and hopefully by spending a
little more time with them,
some of their attitudes,
their beliefs, their mindset,
their way of thinking seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to look at
the best of Eric Thomas 2016 Motivation.
Mentor me, Eric.
Clip number one is my personal
favorite and, as always,
as Eric is talking, if he says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- I need you to do me a favor.
I just need you to expect to win.
Yep, yeah.
Are you like, come on
E, that's simple, look.
Number one, I need you to expect to win.
When you wake up in the
morning, I expect to win.
I expect it to be a great day.
Listen to me very closely.
I do not get up at three
o'clock in the morning to lose.
I used to be a loser, high school dropout.
I used to be a loser, homeless.
I used to be a loser,
eating out of trash cans.
Listen to me, this ain't
no feel good stuff.
I used to be a loser.
Now, listen to me, all I do is win;
and the first thing I did,
I said, look, it's unacceptable.
I will not be a loser.
All I did was say to
myself I expect to win.
Listen to me, when I get up
three o'clock in the morning,
I expect it to be a great day.
When I grind, I expect to win.
When I wake up, I expect a miracle.
I expect that phone call.
I expected to have marital bliss.
I had kids.
I expected to have a great
relationship with my kids.
When I went to school to get
my PhD, I expected to pass.
Are you hearing what I'm telling you?
I wake up every day, and I expect it.
All I need you to do, let's, let's--
don't practice to fail.
Are you practicing to fail?
Are you going to class on time,
doing all your homework to fail?
So number one, mental toughness.
Everything you put your hands forth to do,
expect to be successful,
expect it to be positive.
When you set out for a goal,
expect that it's going to happen.
That's all I need you to do.
Number one, expect it to happen.
What if I told you that you never ever
have to come up short again?
So this is all I need
you to do for me today.
Listen to me, this is all I
need you to do for me today
is to declare that it's over,
that yesterday was the last
day that you were a loser.
Like yesterday was the last
day you expected to lose.
Like yesterday was the
last day you expected,
listen to me, to come up short.
Like, all I need you to do
is declare for me, like,
losing is over.
All I need you to do is speak
up and say I expect to win.
It shall come to pass.
Come on!
Like, look, this is your year.
Yep, this is the year for you to win.
Look, come on, feel it; this is the year.
So you got to do me a huge favor.
I need you to let go of all the fear.
Yep, let, let, let it go.
Yep, let it go.
Anxiety, yep, let it go.
I need you to totally believe.
This is your year to win.
Right, for real, I need you to see it.
I need you to see it.
This is your year, like you crossing over;
and I remember when I crossed over.
I remember, I told you, I remember.
We not talking about being
a high school dropout.
I'm talking about losing.
I remember being a loser.
I know what it feels like.
Like, like, I remember crossing over;
and I remember having to
believe, like, I could do this.
I remember having to believe,
like, yo, this is my year.
Like that monkey off my back.
Like, for real, that
monkey is off my back.
All the stuff that the
teachers that didn't believe.
Like, it's off my back, like academically
I could do this thing.
I started believing, like,
I would get up and speak;
and I wouldn't be afraid anymore.
Like, I need you to
believe me when I tell you,
this is your year.
This is the year to win,
and I'm talking about
you can win, look, as much as you like.
Look, win as often as you like,
win in whatever category you like.
Like, this is the year, all right?
All right?
So I said it to you last
week as we getting ready.
It shall come to pass.
Are you hearing me?
Like, if it shall come to pass,
there's absolutely nothing
that's stopping you.
It shall come to pass.
Like, it's going to happen.
Immediately when I said it,
E, you going get this degree,
boom, it happened!
Immediately when I said it, like ET,
you going to be one of the
top speakers in the world.
Like, ET, you will have an
impact with not just people
in the United States of American, like,
you going to impact the world.
Listen to me once, I believed it.
Once I believed it and
started walking into it, guys,
whoo!
I'm telling you, it became a reality.
So I need you to do me a huge favor:
I need you to understand, alright,
that this is going to be
difficult for some of you guys.
I need you to understand that before
you can totally embrace winning,
some darkness is going to happen.
So between losing and
winning, listen to me,
between losing and winning
it's going to get dark.
Right between winning and
losing it's going to get stormy.
Right?
But you got to promise me
you going to be the KG.
That is the reason why I chose KG, right?
KG's story is very, very unique.
I need you to go back,
I need you to google it,
and do your homework.
2003, not only did they win their division
but they went to the Western
Conference Finals, right?
And they lost, but this is
how it's supposed to go down.
Like once you lose the
Western Conference Finals,
the next year you supposed
to go back and win it,
and you supposed to go the finals.
You may win, you may lose, right?
And then you go back again
to the finals, right?
And then that time you win it all, right?
No, no!
KG went through a storm, you all?
2003 they went to the
Western Conference Finals,
2004 didn't make it back,
2005 didn't make it back,
2006 didn't make it back,
2007 didn't make it back, guys!
Are you hearing what I'm telling you?
So ET, what does KG have to it?
Come on, winning, what does
he have to do with winning?
Listen to me and pick this one up,
this is the most important part:
it will come to pass,
but what you have to promise me is that
in the midst of the storm
you going to grind it out.
In the midst of the storm,
And in the midst of losing,
not only did they lose,
they lost they coach.
There was all kind of
conflict with the play,
like they hit a wall, a
brick wall, but guess what?
KG still was an all-star.
KG Steal won NBA All-Pros team,
second team still won rebound titles.
Are you hearing me?
In the midst of hell,
in the midst of hell,
KG still grind.
And if you can grind your
way through the hell,
if you can grind your
way through that defeat,
way through that pain,
if you can grind your way
through it, I'm telling you,
it's going to come to pass.
And in 2007, the end of the season,
he was drafted to the
Boston Celtics, right?
And it came to pass, you
all! It came to pass!
I'm not telling you what I read.
I'm not telling you what I heard.
I'm telling you what I've experienced,
I'm telling you what I saw.
So you guys do me a favor,
before we get out of here,
listen to me.
Storms going to happen to all of us.
Storms happen to all of us.
Watch the difference, before
we leave, losers get toxic.
Their thinking becomes toxic in the storm.
They start thinking negative,
they start thinking fear.
They start thinking doubt.
They start thinking, "I can't do it."
They start thinking, "The
problem is bigger than I am."
They start thinking toxic.
But winners!
Winners actually use
the storm to fuel them!
Listen to me, losers get weak and give up.
Losers surrender, losers give in.
Listen to me very closely,
but winners are fueled.
They are fueled by storm.
Pain actually pushes them to greater--
they actually love it.
They actually feel it,
they like the pressure.
And they use it as fuel
to get to the next level.
And that's what KG did for me.
Alright guys, I been
watching the Olympics, yeah.
Yup, I been watching the Olympics, right?
And my favorite part, track and field.
Nope, I'm not talking about
Usain Bolt, nope, nope.
We ain't on that, nope.
I'm talking 'about the false starts, yup.
I love it, yo!
You say ET, the false starts, yo,
'cuz I'm tired of people asking me,
"E, why you so passionate?"
Yup, I'm tired of people
saying, "ET, why you so loud?"
"ET, why you aggressive. Why?"
Because the real world,
the real world is like track and field.
And I dunno if you've been
watching or if you paid attention
but you get one false start!
Yup, that's it, guys!
You get one false start, that's it!
You don't get a second chance.
And what I love about these Olympics,
we going to show it to you,
what I love about these
Olympics is one false start,
you out.
That's right, you been working
for four straight years,
you out!
That's absolute, you
won't get a second shot.
Like all that stuff you missed,
you made some serious sacrifices.
Like you got up early in the
morning, get what I'm saying?
You didn't go out with your homies, right?
Look, there were some things
that you had to give up.
For four straight you been
getting up in the morning,
four straight years you been grinding,
four straight years you
been eating different,
been in the weight room,
four straight years you been going in.
And you ruined it all, you
ruined it all with false start.
And you can't say, "Well,
I didn't mean to do this,"
and, "I didn't mean to do
that, I made a mistake."
There are no mistakes.
And that's why I get so passionate.
Cuz in the real world you
don't get 5, 6, 7 chances.
And some of you are going through life,
you're wondering why you not successful.
You wonder why you average,
you wonder why you can't live
the way you deserve to live.
You wondering why you light.
You wondering why you
keep coming up short.
You think 'cuz you say you sorry,
you keep saying, "I didn't mean it."
You keep saying, "My
heart's in the right place."
Look, in the real world
it's like track and field.
They don't care!
You get one false start,
boom, and you out.
So your boy ET is passionate, why?
Well I'll tell you that
you got to make sacrifices,
and you got to get up at three
o'clock and four o'clock,
and you got to grind.
"ET, why you telling me that? Why?"
Because people don't
need help sleeping in.
People don't need help gaining weight.
People don't need help
over-indulging, making excuses.
hitting the snooze button,
people need help making sacrifices.
So as your boy ET tells you, look,
I'm not saying it's going to be easy.
I didn't make up the rules.
I'm not saying you don't need
a third or fourth chance,
I didn't make up the rules,
but what I'm telling you is,
life is like track and field, and Rio.
You don't always get another one.
You don't always get a second one.
You don't always get a third one.
You don't always get a fourth one.
Yup, it's tough, it's hard.
Listen to me, if it was
easy to stay focused
on that start line, everybody would do it.
If it was easy to jump
off with a great start,
everybody would do it!
I'm not telling you it's going to be easy
to get up at three o'clock in the morning.
I'm not telling you it's
going to be easy to sacrifice.
going to be easy to grind.
I'm not telling you it's going to be easy.
But I can tell you this: it
will be worth the sacrifice.
If you can grind your way through it.
So like Usain Bolt, no
excuses, just adjustments.
Execute, my friend.
Execute.
I did not become successful
with two family household,
with the income $250,000.
I was homeless.
I was knocked out, I was
kicked out of school.
I was told never to return,
I did this in the midst of trials,
in the midst of tribulation.
Nobody gave me this, I earned it.
Life wasn't a crystal stair for me,
didn't nobody give me a
network, I earned the network.
I know Warren Buffet
because I worked my way to Warren Buffet.
I worked my way to Dan Gilbert,
I worked my way to the NBA,
I worked my way to the NFL.
Everybody say,"E, how
did you crack the code?"
I grinded my way through the code!
That's how I cracked it.
I got up everyday at three,
every Monday I grind,
Tuesday I grind, Wedn-
I don't care what the economy is doing,
I don't care who the President is,
I don't care who the governor is,
I don't care who the mayor is.
My mamma ain't counting on the governor,
my wife ain't counting on the President
of the United States of America.
My wife ain't counting on the mayor,
my wife ain't counting
on the commissioner.
My wife counting on me.
When I walk out that
house, she's counting on me
to bring home the bacon.
Listen to me, guys:
environment is everything.
Alright, "ET, why is
environment everything?"
Guys, two things, real quick, why.
Because expectation and
exposure, are you hearing me?
Expectation and exposure.
So, catch what I'm saying, right?
This is why you got to get
out of your environment
and get into a new environment
if you going to blow up.
So you got KG, who'd never
been to Boston before.
Oh, come on, come on!
You got Jesus Shuttlesworth,
never been to Boston before.
You got Paul Peirce, who's
been in Boston the whole time.
So they ask the question:
Paul Peirce, what's the
difference between Boston
and everywhere else?
He said, "Expectations."
Here in Boston, you are
expected, listen to me,
don't nobody get excited
about having a winning season,
about the playoffs,
don't nobody get excited
about the Eastern Conference Finals.
In Boston, the expectation
is to win it all.
Are you hearing me?
It's a different level.
There's levels to this, so
much so that Paul Peirce
says we don't even hang up
Eastern Conference banners.
Like, when we win the Eastern Con--
we don't even hang that up!
In Boston we only hang up
Finals banners. That's it!
You win the finals or
you don't win at all!
Look, you think you doing it.
Are you hearing me?
You think you doing it,
you the first one in your
family to go to college, right?
So for you, you been
like, "I'm the first one."
I'm the only one to ever go to college,
and you think you've
done something, right?
You got kids when you go to college,
nobody's excited about the
fact they're in college.
Nobody's excited about the
fact that they graduated.
They want to know, are
you going to be a doctor,
you going to be a lawyer,
you going to be an engineer?
It's a different level.
Paul Peirce said it's environment.
We not even talking about-- come on,
we not even taking about
the Boston Celtics.
We talking about Boston.
Right up the road you got
the New England Patriots,
right up the road you
got the Boston Bruins,
right up the road you got Harvard.
This environment has
a level of expectation
that's out of this world.
And your problem is you're
in an environment of average,
and you good.
And so you good with being good
because your environment is average.
Are you hearing me? So
you think good is great.
Now you told yourself that good is great.
Look, I grew up in Detroit,
no disrespect, right?
But the Lions, they just trying
to have a winning season.
They just trying to
make it to the playoffs.
Are you hearing me?
They just trying to
make it to the playoffs.
If you are a Cowboy, it's win it all.
If you are a Laker, it's win it all.
If you in Boston, it's win
it all, guys! Listen to me!
It's not just about expectation,
it's about exposure.
And when you are a Boston
Celtic you been exposed.
When you were a Laker you been exposed
to the greatest of the great, right?
And so there's a level of expectation.
I'll never forget when
Kobe came to the NBA,
Kobe said, "I'm not playing
for the Charlotte Hornets,
"I'm not playing for
the Charlotte Hornets,
"I want to be a Laker."
And when you walk through
that Laker stadium,
when you walk through that Boston stadium,
all you see is great.
And so because you're
being exposed to great,
all you know is great.
When I came to Michigan State
I was exposed to greatness,
I was exposed to Tom Izzo,
I was exposed to Mark Dantonio,
I was exposed to the Rose Bowl,
I was exposed to the Final Four.
Are you hearing what I'm
saying? I got around greatness
and so I had no choice but to be great.
So I ask you the question:
what's your expectations?
What do you want for yourself?
What do you want for your family?
What do you want for the next generation?
What do you expect of yourself?
Listen to me very closely,
it's not what coach wants for you,
it's not what your mamma want for you,
it's not what your daddy want for you,
it's not what your teacher wants for you.
It's not what everybody
else wants for you.
What do you want for
yourself? What drives you?
What pushes you, what motivates
you, what makes you tick?
What activates you? What are
you expectations for yourself?
And then ask yourself, when
you wake up every morning,
what are you being exposed to?
And if you don't like the places you see,
if you don't like where you going,
if you don't like what
life is showing you,
get in an environment of greatness
so you can be exposed to greatness.
And by beholding, we become changed.
By beholding, we become changed.
What are you beholding?
Where your focus goes, your energy flows.
And so if you focusing in on the negative,
guess what's going to happen?
Your energy is going
to go to the negative,
and everything is going to be negative
because that's where your focus is.
That's where you energy
is flowing, listen to me.
If you think about that thing,
you concentrate on winning.
You concentrate on dominating.
Listen to me, whatever you focus on,
where your focus goes your energy flows.
So we going to think about
what we thinking about.
We going to think about
And when we think about
those things which are pure,
listen to me, come on!
That stuff that's true, right?
Whatsoever things are pure,
whatsoever things are true,
whatsoever things are lovely,
whatsoever things are of good report,
are you hearing me?
Meditate on this stuff,
focus on this stuff,
it don't mean negative
things won't happen,
but we not focusing on
it. Are you hearing me?
It don't mean that negative
things won't transpire,
that as you go through the day
something bad won't happen,
but we not going to meditate on it.
We going to focus on what's positive,
we going to focus on what's good, right?
And when we focus on that,
that's where our energy's going to go.
And what's going to happen is the outcomes
are going to reflect our thinking.
I'm feel your pain, you
like, "E, it ain't easy!
"You don't know where I come from, ET!
"It ain't just that easy
to go from where I am
"to get this new circle of influence."
I feel you, yup, yup, yup.
I've read the comments, like,
"ET, you don't understand, E,
"you don't know the
environment that I was born in.
"ET you don't know how hard it
is to get to where you said."
Look, I get it!
And then I got teachers
that have called me,
teachers that have reached
out like, "ET, you don't know
"where these kids come from, ET!
"You don't understand
their circumstances, ET!
"You giving them this
dream that they can get
"in a different circle."
Listen to me, listen to me very--
whatcha want me to do? Come one!
Whatcha want me to do,
whatcha want me to tell you
to accept the life that you've been given?
Huh? Whatcha want?
You want me to tell you to give up? Huh?
You want me to tell you to quit?
Is that what you want me to say?
You want to hear ET say,
"It's alright to give up.
"It's alright to surrender."
That's what you want me to say?
Well listen to me, bra,
I can't tell you that.
But what I can tell you
is this: that I did it.
And I used one thing,
I know it ain't easy.
I come from where you come
from. I been there, I done that.
It wasn't easy for me to
get to where I am right now.
I used two things and two things only.
Ain't nobody give me no
money to get out the hood.
Didn't nobody give me to resources
to get out of that abandoned building.
I used two things and two things only:
one, my mind. I envisioned
myself getting out.
And two, my heart.
And you can't measure that.
That's right, and you can't measure that.
So listen to me, I'm not
about to tell you to quit.
I'm not about to tell you
that you going to keep that cycle going.
I'm going to tell you to break that cycle.
So listen to me,
you can get in a different
circle of influence.
You can, you can get to another level.
But it's going to take two
things. Are you hearing me?
I got here from my mind,
and I envisioned it.
I saw myself when I was still homeless,
when I was still a high school dropout,
when I was sleeping in
abandoned buildings,
and eating out of trash cans.
I saw myself someday being
where I am right now.
I don't care where you
are, use what you got
to get what you want.
Use your mind, use your
vision, use your dream.
I dreamed my way out the hood.
I dreamed my way out, and then I saw it.
And I would get up every
day and I would grind hard.
I would grind my way through it.
So listen to me, I'm
going to tell you a story.
First gig I ever did
in my life was Bermuda.
Listen to me, I dreamed about
Bermuda for eight months
before I got there.
I'm not playing with you,
I can't make this stuff up.
Are you hearing me? I went to the library,
and I read about it.
I asked my friends that were
from Bermuda about Bermuda,
and they told me about the water,
and they told me about the palm trees,
and they told me about the island.
Are you listening to what I'm telling you?
I dreamed it, eight, six,
eight months, I dreamed it.
I thought about it, I read
about it, listen to me,
from where I was.
Are you hearing me? From where I was.
In college, not doing well,
from where I was I dreamed it.
Not from Bermuda, I didn't
dream it from Bermuda.
I dreamed it from where
I was, in the library,
in my house, walking
up and down that street
thinking about it.
And on everything I love,
I can't explain it to you,
but the James family,
the husband and wife,
knocked on my small
apartment door one day,
with me and my wife sitting there,
and they walked in with two plane tickets.
Two plane tickets to
Bermuda, are you hearing me?
And a two week itinerary of every church,
and every school, and every
youth detention center
that I was going to speak at.
And listen to me, it went
from a dream I'll never forget
when I got my passport, ahh!
I'll get when I landed
on the island of Bermuda,
I said to myself, "How in the world?"
And God said, "It was your mind!"
As a man thinketh, so is he.
Think your way out of
it, grind your way out.
And I got up every day after
I dreamed about Bermuda.
And I went to that GED
class, and I put in work.
I went in and I read to
them, and I spoke to them,
and I inspired them and I motivated them.
So I leave you with this, listen to me:
change your circle of influence.
Change your circle of influence.
Change your life.
Know they may not give it to you,
but whatcha want me to do?
You want me to tell you it's okay to quit?
You want me to tell you
it's okay to surrender?
They may not give it to you.
Nobody might take you by
the hand and take you there.
You might not get a mentor, I don't know.
But what I'm telling you is,
I did it with my mind and my heart.
And if I can do it,
starting from the bottom,
now we here, starting from the bottom.
I started with my mind,
I started with my heart.
You got a mind, you got a
heart, stop making excuses!
Stop waiting for somebody
to feel sorry for you.
And to my teachers out there,
and to my mentors out there,
stop giving them the paths to quit!
Yes it's going to be hard, yes
it's going to be difficult,
but you can do it!
Listen to me, you, your
boy ET telling you,
I did it, you can do it.
Now a lot of you all people
talking about the Black Mamba,
the Black Mamba, let
me tell you something.
When you talk about the Black
Mamba you talk about practice,
It's a must have.
I watched this dude lose a game, a game,
I don't even know if it was the playoffs.
I think it was like a regular
game against the Miamia Heat,
in Miami.
Southeast Florida.
I don't know if you
ever been there before,
but it's, you want to go, it's
a nice place to just hang out.
Especially if you on
the roll playing ball,
that's a nice plays after
the game to go get dinner,
sit on the beach, it's nice.
And I'm sure in the NBA
they probably got a VIP
section for them on the beach.
And unfortunately,
the Lakers lost to the Miami Heat
because Black Mamba
missed a wide open shot
in the corner, set shot and he missed it.
What he did for the
next three to four hours
while everybody was getting
dressed and going to the beach
he sat there for hours,
shooting the exact same
shot over and over and over,
like he had never won a championship.
I'm like, now hold up,
where everybody else at
on the Lakers?
They need to be out there as a squad.
But the Black Mamba's out
there doing his thing,
like I'm not owing them, I messed up,
I got to practice.
And this is not a coach
practice, this is not
an organization you can call this one,
this was just flat out,
the Black Mamba was saying
this is a must-have.
And where most of you go wrong,
you not even 4.0 and you not studying.
You not even a 4.0 student, like you got
a 2.0, a 2.5, a 3 something?
And you still not really
studying like that,
because for you it's like,
ahh, it's not a must-have.
It blows my mind, I worked
with professional athletes,
I work with D1 athletes
all over the world.
And when I look at Twitter and Instagram,
it blows my mind how dudes on Instagram,
I'm like bra, you have
not won a championship!
Like that's what you come here for,
to win a championship!
And so if you don't win
championship, I don't even
know why there's people broke.
I don't even know how you had enough time
to do a 30 second video, you broke!
How did you have time to do a video,
how did you have time
to do a dance routine?
When you should be practicing!
You should be lifting weights,
you could be looking at film.
You said, not me, that you
wanted to win the tourney.
That you want to win it all, you
want to go to the Final Four.
How do you want to go to the Final Four,
but your schedule don't
look like the Final Four.
What are you tweeting
about when you broke?
You about to get kicked
out on academic probation,
what are you tweeting about?
What are you talking about?
Why do you even have friends?
Why do you have friends,
what do you need friends for?
They're not helping you study.
They're trying to
convince you to do stuff,
gimme one second, listen
to me very closely,
I'm not trying to disrespect
your little friends.
But if they your real friends,
and they not helping you to get this,
what kind of friends are they?
Who are they?
If this your homebody and he don't know
what your dreams and goals are,
if it's your homegirl and she don't know
what your dreams are,
if they inviting you to parties,
if they inviting you to the movies,
but they ain't never invited you to study,
what kind of friend are they really?
Cuz all my friends, this what we owe.
Now, this is the thing, and I
want you to be real with me,
is we got one or two problems.
Either you're a liar,
and what you wrote down,
you weren't really serious about.
You just did it 'cuz it was cute.
Or you really want it.
One of the two.
And you got to decide
if what you wrote down,
if you really want it or not.
I can't sit here and lie,
and tell you that my faith
has not helped me to get to where I am.
I want you to listen to this word.
Because it's a word that is
used in the spirit realm,
it's not a word that's used in the flesh.
And why most of you will never
be successful in your craft
is because you're chasing a dollar
and you don't honor your craft.
I honor what I do, I
honor it, it's sacred.
The people are sacred.
And that's why most of you chasing money,
like you doing this for the money,
you'll never blow up because
it's not sacred to you.
When something is scared
you spend time with it.
When something is sacred
you take your doggone shoes off,
'cuz where you stand is holy ground.
It's holy ground, it's sacred.
It's your life.
It's your life, you putting
your life in my hand.
You sitting here listening to me,
I'm putting words in your spirit.
I'm imparting ideas into your spirit,
that ain't no joke, that ain't no game.
When I come into this place,
I didn't eat on the plane.
They serving me food, I'm
like, "I can't eat it."
They like, "You in first class, sir,
"Somebody ordered a quiche for you."
"I can't eat the quiche right now."
He's like, "Why not?"
I'm like, "There might be something in it,
"I can't afford to get sick, I can't eat."
I can't afford to put food in my mouth
if I don't know where it came from.
I can't afford,
this is the airplane, ain't no telling
where this stuff come from!
Nobody wash they hands, I don't know!
I got three gigs, I got to
be ready when I get there.
Don't gimme that water.
I need bottled water.
Don't bring me no water in no cup.
I dunno where that came from.
I needed to open it 'cuz I
got people who spent money,
and I cannot say I'm sick.
I can't tell these people I'm sick!
Your stuff needs to be sacred.
You don't even know what
to do if you don't know
who you are.
And so I want to tell you
what nobody's told you,
perhaps your mom didn't tell you today,
perhaps your dad didn't tell you today,
I dunno maybe your
teacher had an attitude,
and she didn't say it
before you left school,
but you are a amazing!
Yup, I said it, bring it here.
I said it, you are amazing.
That's right, I'm going to say it again.
You are amazing.
And you need to understand
something, I do not get
paid to do this.
I been doing this for eight years.
I have no sponsors.
I don't think somebody sent me
like five dollars to do this.
"So ET, why would you keep
doing it year after year?
"Month after month, week after week, why?"
Because I know something about you
that you may not know about yourself.
You are amazing!
And it's time for you
to act like you amazing.
It's time for you to
do the amazing, right?
It's time for you to know you are amazing.
So listen to me, I'm going
to give you an assignment.
But before we go there,
I got to let you know
I'm telling you the truth.
Now when I a high school
dropout, when I was homeless,
when I was getting kicked out of school,
I'm just going to keep doing 100,
I did not know I was amazing.
I told you before, no disrespect,
but my biological father
wasn't in my life,
so I didn't have him to tell
me when I got up every day,
"ET, you are amazing!"
Like me and my mom had some challenges,
so my mom wasn't necessarily telling me,
"You are amazing." Right?
And so I was eating out
of trash cans, right?
Listen to me, I was getting
kicked out of school.
Like I was in the malls,
stealing from the mall,
getting in trouble,
getting arrested, listen.
And some pastor brought
me to church, right?
And I'm telling you, my man would tell me
on a weekly basis,
"You are amazing. And it's
time for you to act amazing."
And do the amazing.
So I want to say this to you real quick,
you are not your test score.
Are you hearing me? Look at ET!
I never done well on a standardized test.
You are not your grades, you are amazing.
You are not what happened
to you, where you were born,
what circumstance you come from.
You are amazing.
You hear me? You are amazing.
The day you recognize you amazing,
the day you understand
how amazing you are,
everything changes.
Look, my standardized
tests, they didn't change.
My test scores didn't change.
My grades didn't necessarily
change like that.
It's when I became aware of
the fact that I'm gifted,
that I'm special, and I need
you to understand something,
when you recognize who you are,
when you realize how amazing you are,
there's certain things you
not going to do no more.
When you recognize how amazing you are,
there's certain people you not
going to hang around no more.
When you realize how amazing you are,
there just certain things
you not going to do no more.
Because eagles and pigeons
don't run together.
And when you realize,
sweetheart, that you an eagle,
my brother when you realize you a king,
my sister when you realize you a queen,
things are going to change, why?
'Cuz queens don't do
what everybody else do.
Kings don't do what everybody else do.
And so I'm telling you, you are amazing.
Now draw me a line.
And I want you to do me a favor,
that's right, I said it, draw a line.
And I just want you to
put one thing on there.
As a matter of fact, two things:
put "amazing" and put
"super duper amazing."
I just want you to write
down all the things
that make you amazing.
Like for real, just sit down, for real,
I don't care about your teacher
when he talking about grades right now.
I'm not talking about
what you did in school,
what you didn't do in school.
I'm not talking about where you were born,
where you come from, we're
not talking about that.
Look, all that aside,
I just want you to write
down, "I'm amazing. Why?"
I'm a people person, I'm amazing,
I'm intelligent in my
own right, I'm amazing.
I'm an artist, I'm amazing, I do music,
I'm amazing, I love people, whatever,
I don't know what it is, I'm amazing, ET.
Everything that makes you special.
Everything that makes you you.
Then I want you to get up, listen to me,
I love you guys, that's
why I do what I do.
Now it's time for you to
recognize how amazing you are.
Right? So just do that for me.
Just write down how amazing you are,
I just want you to look
at it in the morning,
look at it at night, look
at it in the evening,
and I'm not telling
something I read in a book,
or somebody told me.
I'm telling you, I went
from being who I was
to who I am now.
And guess what? My biological father
never came back in my life.
Like, I'm being 100, nothing changed,
but I woke up one day
and I realized, yo E,
so what, your father wasn't in your life.
You still amazing.
So what, you got kicked out
of Detroit Public School?
You're still amazing.
So what, you ate out of trash cans?
You still amazing!
And there's nothing your
circumstances could do about it.
And so the difference between
the old ET and the new ET,
is that I know by the
grace of God I'm amazing.
And you are amazing, too.
So I need you to do me a favor,
I want you to start acting like it.
This your boy ET saying I
love you, I believe in you,
and now it's time for
you believe in yourself.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I love to know what did you think?
Did you enjoy this video,
are you motivated now?
It's hard not to be after
watching all of that ET.
I'm curious to know, though, which clip
had the biggest impact on you?
What lesson did you learn from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow.
Leave it in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Also want to give out a quite
shout out to Devon Triche,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word,
and posting that picture to Instagram,
I really, really, really
appreciate it, man.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll seeya soon.